citizens of the reject Nation it's meteor Erickson
alongside my friend say your name I'm Aaron hello
full name Alexander thank you find you Aaron today
we're gonna watch Saul and neither of us have seen
it saw you have not seen it I've never seen a
single saw I never saw a saw oh my goodness he
never saw saw that's sad because I've been to Home
Depot seen many listen guys you gotta leave a like
you gotta type in your computer you gotta leave
a comment and you guys know you got a ring now
[Music]
also guys thanks to uh prepper for the edit yep
and also don't forget to uh become the Patriots
you can watch the full length Reaction watch
along with your own copy and be a part of the
super sexy reject Nation you guys know how that
goes and if you don't know how it goes you just
get on patreon and then you're like oh now I see
how it goes Greg and John also cover several shows
exclusively over there with reaction highlights
and watch alongs included so you know get over
there do the business I haven't slept in four days
because I've been doing an overnight shoot so if
this seems clunky that's why okay you got anything
to say about saw or my performance here today
Aaron uh I think you're killing it four days of no
sleep yeah overnight shoots you guys so right now
I'm on and off schedule are we ready to watch Saw
I feel like oh yeah we're ready I can't say F-bomb
foreign [Music]
yeah okay
the dude from Princess Bride yes oh wow
and recognize him about his mustache
Shane I don't think that's gonna work I thought
it would be helpful Chief yeah if you get like
a little flame and just like keep it there maybe
I've seen that in a movie Once what's your name
my name is very [__] confused what's your name
what's going on here my name is Lawrence Gordon
I just woke up here just like you
you're way too calm about this for
a guy just woke up yeah except I feel
like he was the guy talking in the dark
um okay what's the last thing you remember I
went to bed in my [__] apartment and woke up
in an actual [__] I was on my way home from Mark
and I don't remember anything else you gonna tell
me your name Adam that clock somebody obviously
wanted us to know the time interesting yeah weird
where'd you find it it's in my
pocket doesn't that guy in the
ground have a tape recorder he
does have a tape recorder yeah
a little snap to be getting into it now
getting into it we're starting to cook
there's your life [Laughter] but who
gets to play it first and a bullet and
there's a gun oh snap someone's gonna kill
someone God they're gonna have to choose
I bet used to the door throw it over
here foreign I mean what's he gonna
do right I mean well I have the one
bullet he doesn't have a bullet right
oh God are they gonna be like each one of them
Out Of Reach of that oh that's terrible how
what are you sure oh your shirt oh
yes okay so I thought he fell asleep
like that or the whoever kidnapped them and
put the shirts on right put clothes on them
take him outside the box God also but that
guy has a the other one has a blue shirt on
and he could be reaching for the gun and he is
a bullet he could yeah he has an undershirt on
it must be something a dirty ass bathtub that's
right he woke up in that it's a dream stopper
it is a dream oh yeah
oh nice getting close I got it nice
or I'll tell you where you might
be you might be in the room that
you die in I am scared to see what this tape says
someone angry yet empathetic but
mostly just pathetic so you're
going to watch yourself die today
Adam Gordon you have given people
that they're gonna die soon now you will need
a cause of death your aim in this game is
to kill her until six on the clock to do what
until what oh my God if you do not kill Adam
by six then Allison and Diana will die last one
Allison and Diana this is awkward the game began
what follow your heart oh [__] that means kill
Adam because his heart was with his
family x marks the spot though also
um
poopy heart oh this is where the key comes in huh
maybe oh God yes thank you oh my God please no
I can
[Music] nope nope nope nope oh [Music] my
God why oh God oh so y'all better not make
me vomit in a room nobody told me this movie
was sponsored by Taco Bell oh [__] oh [__]
[Laughter]
please let it be something normal
oh my god oh title of the movie
oh and they both have one two saws God yeah
I mean it's like God there is no you're gonna
run you're gonna like they're gonna make the saw
not useful anymore yeah dum dum dummy dum dum dum
through our feet only one of you can now
I think I may know who's done this to us
really oh it's not someone I know personally
it's just someone I know of oh last I heard
police still hadn't caught him the
only reason I know that is because I
was a suspect oh I know that guy yeah he
looks so young right Danny Glovers okay
oh what the hell is going on here
yo victims of 46 year old male
died of massive blood loss oh that's
rough oh that's yeah it's gross he
started at the back of the Cajun tunneled
his way through that razor wire so fast
it's amazing he got as far as he did oh wow
we also found this what Bud Light oh no oh it's
a tape okay look like a can for a second you want
to die you just have to stay where you are but if
you want to live you'll have to cut yourself again
he's alive at three o'clock that door
will lock and then this room becomes your
tomb oh no it's watching flashback
he was given two hours oh my God
the jigsaw killer technically speaking easy not
really a murderer oh right he's just like setting
he finds ways for his victims to kill themselves
interesting selling traps if you're so sick then
why do I have so many photos of you up and about
there's a slow acting poison in your veins the
antidote is inside the safe combination to the
safe history on the wall oh but watch your step
that's a flammable substance smeared on your
body oh God just might have their Revenge oh
my goodness freaking gracious wow awful looks like
our friend jigsaw likes to book himself front row
seats to his own sick little games he left us his
pen right does he want to be found this patient
has an inoperable frontal lobe tumor extending
across the midline started as colon cancer the
patient had his name is John oh this guy from Lost
yeah it's a very interesting person thank you for
that information orderly's form very special
bonds with the patience give me sus Vibes guy
obviously someone doesn't want me to
tell you what the patient has excuse me
girl you're in school right now are you able to
tell us where you were between the hours of 11
pm and 1am why is it that you're interested you
[__] around with that girl it's best if we do
it down at the station that's quite I can't just
leave I have my wife has oh he's a cheater too
this is your doctor oh so the killer was a
patient maybe like and he told him you're
gonna die right and that and the guy he must have
taken his pen look if you can't be honest with
me I was visiting someone it wasn't a patient I
was cheating on my wife I checked your Alibi it
holds up we have one of the victims who managed to
escape want to know if you wouldn't mind sticking
around and listening to her testimony this man's
wearing a jean jacket for a blazer [Laughter]
he's ahead of his time he's ahead of
his time the first thing you remember
I woke up I could taste was blood oh my God
oh spooky
ripped oh my God I'll show you no
don't do that no no I don't like it
oh the demonstration is so unnecessary
there was only one key device
soulmate ugh
[Music] yeah girl meddle it out [Music]
oh my God no ah but her mouth was bleeding in
the room [Music] I don't want it she did it she
when she's there yeah but is her mouth weird
it's a little weird and then I saw the body
that person don't look dead to me
[Music]
did you have to cut the question mark oh God
oh my God oh my God
he's alive oh my god [Music] oh she's doing
it oh but it's definitely not in the shape
of a question mark she's just going at it you
didn't follow the lines no you're supposed to
trace oh you killed the you killed that guy
you killed the poop out of that guy oh oh
crap oh God
seems like she got it light compared to
the other ones oh yeah he's just gonna
have to live with those memories
forever yeah okay maybe she didn't
oh boy what is that keeps going should be over she
should have escaped what is this what's going on
oh that's terrifying a puppet on a tricycle
why is it like that why is it sweating oh God
all right not anymore why are you moist
oh and
that is why he picked you you sting why
is he picking the people he's picking
he helped me they say helped her
no you either tell me what is really going
on or I'll cut you with this you hear me
oh oh is it two-way glass
camera
okay part of me feels like that body's not
dead that's what I was gonna say because the
other one wasn't and I'm like but can a dead
body stay face down like that on the ground
without moving for six hours like you'd have to
be a sociopath right because he said he had from
10 until I mean how long have they been there
I mean that body's got makeup on the back yeah
like a sedative or something how can
you be the calm doctor guy when your
wife and kid are out there thinking
about that I am thinking about that
oh my God [Laughter] Aaron's gonna give
me a freaking heart attack oh my goodness
what is there something there no thank you
oh he was home oh he's home
okay I'm in a bad dream again
just gotta finish this paragraph I imagine
it's the Kool-Aid man in the room oh yeah
have to go to work sweetheart you
know what daddy's job is like now
come on you know Daddy has to
collect those bands [Music]
you're happy I am happy that is complete
[__] oh and it's probably your wallet he
lets you keep your wallet though I mean it's not
useful at this point it was nice of him that's
kind look at him keeping his wallet you can
take his money beautiful so where's the lucky
wife there's another pitcher behind the one
you're looking at it oh God does he know oh
my God oh God x marks the spot sometimes
you see more with your eyes shut ah this
photo you're talking about is not here we're
just gonna keep the Polaroid of his family huh
that's messed up
you're creepy that's the Lost
guy was it it looks like his eye
it really looked like the Lost
guy's eye what is in a sheet
oh why is that so terrifying that he's just in
standing there in a blanket I hate it I hate it
[Music] poor girl that little girl is a great
little actor she's going
through hell I believe her
oh
wait
that's not is it Danny Glover yeah so wait what's
going on now why is he there what's happening I am
so confused why does he have the camera and he's
looking what I never should have let you go oh
missing person discovered at bizarre
Museum oh did he walk into the guy's
apartment what's what's going on I'm
so confused here Alibi it holds up
meaning like
like what an amazing story that poor woman
told we keep jumping around with the events
so is this happening while the families get
kidnapped no I think this is a flashback a
flashback within the flashback we arrested at
Dennis last week we like to play with kids a
bit too much he lived two blocks from here
the sewer lines run under this neighborhood
too because present day is what's happening
in the room right but this is a flashback
but the also the his family getting captured
is a flashback too yes remember 118th Street
k2k that game's territory was only
about four blocks now listen to this
is that a bell is that a school like sounds
like check the directions for all the fire
emergencies that occurred in that area within
the last two weeks two 13 stygian Street
okay let's figure it out dang this makes me want
Krispy Kreme though but I cannot eat
it during this movie no way in hell
laughs I love how Danny
Glover holds guns in movies
always ass out
arm stretched ass out that's funny
oh it's a replica of the guys
all of the traps she's ever done to
this point must be right it's like
I'm gonna fight this movie ah what is that thing
nope
oh my god oh it's a guy oh why we got him
that saw is gonna go and it's
gonna screw into his head y'all
no don't pull the thing I feel like
oh God oh God oh awake already Jeff
powerful track for tranquilizers
next time you're a test subject
for something greater than yourself
get him get him come on now get him
no [__] now you'll make a choice
just two of you kill him and then
save him okay he will unlock it
where is it you're frustrating
shoot him and make him do it don't play his
game [Music] you have The High Ground what
are you guys doing giving in demands right
now for the life of another human being
take his hood off come on now
there it is thank you thank you oh
my goodness
junk yeah you guys come on now you're being
dumb you're being dumb movie characters oh
my God not this is not good ideas why
would you give him enough time to okay
I don't trust these cops anymore I
don't think they're good at their
job you should have shot him when you
had the chance you had the perp there
just shoot him thank you like that might
not be that might have been some decoy yeah
no no don't do it don't do it oh no
no no no
oh yeah
no head what is going on
that's what you guys get for being dumb not the
freeze frame so now because the killer used the
word tranquilizer I don't think that guy in
the room is dead I think you're right [Music]
oh he's lost his mind right now turn off
the lights oh it might glow good idea
yeah x marks the spot there we
what I want to know is why these two
guys specifically in the same room
because this is his right first not this
I guess his first two alive person trap
well now the other guy was alive with the
girl but this is like a man versus Man Trap
that's the keys too oh yeah
don't if it freaking bounces and or a
door or something I'm gonna be so mad
I think you got it is there another gun
or is it another bullet a cell phone and a
lighter and cigarettes is that cigarettes in
there most beautiful invention on this planet are
you guys hopeful as if he hasn't coordinated this
whole thing make that second most beautiful
invention are you serious dude the cigarettes
are harmless I promise smoking is only poisonous
when it ends in Bloodshed I'm trying the police
no one said the phone had signal This was
meant to receive calls not make them this is
this is four last night I'm
sure someone else was there
oh he's in the car the whole time
oh my God what is this what is that
oh my God is that that weird pig mask I think it
is what the oh my God this is Ah hell to the no to
the no no no no no no no no no no no that's what
gotta be here that's what got him here we still
know nothing about the other guy we know nothing
about that other guy yeah you're right we don't
here it is where did you get
this it was in your wallet
what are you doing he's gonna be like I'm gonna
get the gun in the bullet and I'm gonna kill
Adam you don't need a gun to kill him when
there's that much poison in your blood oh
so he could put the you say the cigarette in the
gun I was like in the no in the blood because the
blood is poisonous and maybe it explodes no this
is all wrong I'm just like what in the is this
there has to be yeah like put it in the blood but
what is it gonna oh oh and then give it to him
you still want that cigarette
terrible so bad the worst actor I've
killed him with the poison just like
you wanted now where's my family hello
what the f that's electrocuted the chain
oh nope can't outsmart him
you guys know you gotta cut your foot
off have we not learned the lesson from
him from Eminem you're gonna break the
other Solitude you guys are so dumb you
said it out loud doctor he wants us to
saw through our feet what are you doing
I remember how I got here oh now we
get to see your story okay [Applause]
a photographer interesting
oh what
what what [Music] maybe he's not working for
jigsaw but maybe the wife because she suspected
the husband of cheese oh right that she was like
go take pictures I didn't understand that last
shot why there was like a peephole or like a yeah
I think they're trying to mislead us thinking it
was related to the other crime from earlier with
the guy with who got set on fire someone there
[Laughter]
killing me I think it's the tricycle
she's sitting there yeah
[Music]
oh he only had he had deal six to kill him so
now he's like 20 minutes right oh God now it's on
Diana I'm scared Daddy oh
everybody ruined here yeah
there's another gun there's two of them
there's more than one person because one
person's watching them while other ones
with the family oh yeah is Adam there
how do you know how do you know Adam don't
believe Adam's lies oh what he knows you
he knew all about you before today because
you might be right but if you don't call that
did I just call that but why would she say
his lies how does she know he is lying like
did she I think maybe the guy told her
to say that yeah it's a great mistrust
who are you you know who I am stop the
line [Applause] what did you do last
night Lawrence oh work at a hospital yeah
saving sick children he's the investor yep
called the baby you don't recall getting
your picture taken in that parking lot
are you the pictures that the whole time I
get paid to take pictures of rich guys like
you who go to CD out of the way motels they're
secretaries had these with you the whole time
found them in there with the hacksaws oh
it's out of curiosity what did you do in
that motel room get out of there pretty fast
um secretary yeah nursing student what's
wrong with me to make you come
here but I thought we I'm sorry
it's for you I know what you're doing he
knows what he's doing but is it because he
knows because of the guy's pictures because of
Adam's pictures or he's just also following him
he's also following him yeah the person who paid
you to follow me who was it he calls himself Bob
and he gives me the money up front what did he
look like now he's a guy he's a tall black guy
he's got a scar around his neck okay Clover
you could have started with that [Laughter]
I don't know what he looks like he's just
a tall black guy with a scar like yeah
what detected up he was discharged from
the police force the guy became obsessed
convinced himself that I must have somehow been
involved with the murders I mean it's crazy
what are you more pissed off about the
fact that I took some shots of you or the
fact that I took some shots of you while
you were cheating on your wife oh my God
oh you remember something else oh you see
something else what what are you saying
oh he's in the picture
I know him zap
what oh God what we're out of time
what happens now happens now
well he said he would kill
oh
I was doing this from their house what Dr Gordon's
time is up I'm afraid it has to
be you that tells him he failed
you son of a [__] so Barky you failed
oh yeah girl get it get it get it get it
stay on the ground bro you should
give me the phone let me get your
neck cut like Danny Glover come on where are you
I know I'm being held captive in a room somewhere
please forgive me I've always been happy
well we all saw that coming a bunch of dummies
in this some people's [__] bro I swear
my goodness
got him wait how how is he right there
oh he's just was obsessed watching them
the whole time I guess so okay well how
is he so close and ready and available
was he like in the apartment next door or
something from us he must be [Applause] then
why was he having him take the pictures
of the doctor before he even got kidnapped
yes
I'm gonna kill your husband now Mrs Gordon
that's the cartoony little yeah and
Kelly husband now a little dog too
I didn't know why he was so close I oh my
goodness dang now who's doing this to you is
it on a timer it's helper oh maybe a timer who
is your helper is it the dead guy on the floor
it's weird that this guy hasn't just killed
Danny right now right because he sees him in
the car driving up right he could just like so
but who electrocuted him timer might be right or
like a helper well it's a helper get the box and
scrape the phone to you we have the technology
yeah you can also take off your
button-up shirt as that guy did
your shirt take your shirt off oh my
goodness take it off come on all right
I literally had a gunfight Joe to another
location to continue the gun fight yeah
we're just gonna have to sire leg off I mean
he's a doctor he's gonna know how to cut off
the circulation so maybe maybe he'll use his
shirt to cut the circulation I'm sure he will
listen to you yeah there we go there we go
this is dumb I knew he's gonna do that
but he could also use the shirt to grab
the phone you could be phoning it up and
cutting your leg off at the same time buddy
also I don't know if that was a tight
enough tie with that shirt I'll be honest
[Laughter]
he didn't have to do that guys you didn't have to
you didn't have to die oh he really didn't
retired man I absolutely could have
you're too old for this [__] yeah
he didn't have to do that you could
have just grabbed the phone guy
you get through to him it's all
right I've called the police
[Music]
it's the rules
what was this part of the plan I don't know
oh yeah good good yeah Adam is the only one
with good ideas oh my God finally somebody
kill this guy oh my God no don't try and stop
him okay guys and bloody white shirts [Music]
the phone y'all get the phone get the phone the
freaking phone y'all there's a phone in there
we still don't have an explanation for why Danny
Glover was taking so close yeah we don't oh
so far tape recorder hello Mr Handle or
as they called you around the hospital
I want you to make a choice [Music]
slow acting poison coursing
through your system which only
I have the antidote for will you murder
a mother and her child to save yourself
uh uh so we still don't know the
guy yet he's part of the game
called it I called it oh no oh no
oh my God [Music] oh my God who the
f is this oh my God oh boy oh okay
to that chain is in the bathtub what what oh
Daddy's sink in that light in the light thing
[Music] it's a very interesting person I knew it
oh cause he knew his name hello Mark Paul Amanda
I want to play a game
[Music]
most people are so ungrateful to
be alive but not you game over
oh my God that guy's just gonna be locked in
the room with and like I starved to death whoa
whoa did he make it to the other guy make it to
his family which guy oh that guy there's no way
he bled to death but he was crawling out maybe
there's no way there is oh my god oh wow I can't
with this I cannot no thank you I knew it was the
guy on the floor oh my God oh my God cause he was
there but then no one was ever paying attention
to them and they always had reverse yeah like
yes exactly but I want you to forget about him I
also thought that like maybe they which one's the
volume to this this thing I also thought that
maybe they um that they like from in my brain
I was like oh they're probably cutting around
the extras so they didn't this is that a live
guy didn't have to lie there every time they had
footage oh right but I think you're more right
because the guy would just be like I'm getting
paid just lay there and like look dead but that
would be like tough you thought it was like a
logistical thing I did like to have him there
the whole time and you know he looks real because
I looked a few times to be like do we think that
that might be a dummy for some shots and it's not
it's always a real obviously a real body and I was
like oh it'd probably be a lot to have them either
yeah probably both it probably is wrong there yeah
well I I also think it would just be hard for like
because if he breathes at all right you're having
a guy lay there and just be like don't move at all
I would hate that job oh my gosh okay so tell me
your thoughts initial like initial first thoughts
what are you feeling my initial first thoughts on
my feeling I'm feeling shocked I'm feeling yeah
like that was a ride we just went on that was a
roller coaster I Now understand why this is a
10 movie franchise yeah right that was crazy
I'm also I'm like wow how did I go so long like
this movie's like what 20 plus years old yes I
knew nothing about it this entire time that was
crazy yeah me neither I think it's like crazy
too that this movie obviously there's a reason it
probably blew up became viral became like a name
but everyone loves it and at the same time I get
it's the the classic Trope of horror movie dummy
Dum Dum Dums who never kill the killer that I
want to strangle it was so frustrating just shoot
the so easy it's right there oh my God but
still like really liked it even mixed with
the frustration but also I'm like why was Danny
Glover so close to the house is it just because
he was obsessed so it would make sense if he
was obsessed because he's been stalking that
guy assume that guy had something to do with it
yeah but why would Danny hire the guy to take the
pictures that part we never got answers to maybe
maybe in the sequel we find out but yeah that part
is kind of a hole that we have that hasn't been
filled yeah like oh my God ah my favorite part
is seeing the guy get up in the background and
you're like oh my goodness also that little girl
10 out of 10. so good she is really good and
I know that the mom the blonde hair I forget
her name she worked a lot it probably still
works now I just haven't seen her in a while
she worked a lot and like when was this made like
early 2000s or late 90s or something maybe 2000
2004 or somewhere around that I like her too I
mean everybody in this movie movie is actually
legitimately really good I believed everyone uh
and oh the pig why did it have to have hair why
does it have to have a full head of hair pigs
have hair sometimes terrifying a wig no they
don't awful the one pig that came up that kill him
in the garage is like full head of hair I can't
be doing that I didn't realize the pig thing was
from Saw because I've been to like horror nights
and stuff and seen the guy with the pig but I
never put it together if it was from this movie
Pig with a wig now we know what was your favorite
part oh man I think my favorite part might have
been uh the whole scene where Danny Glover and his
partner went to see the guy and he had like the
ass poking I thought that was funny [Laughter]
oh but yeah his favorite part of saw was Danny
Glover's butt out while holding a gun it looks so
ridiculous it's hilarious oh man I don't know the
whole thing was just like a ride like I like the
the non-linear storytelling because like you're
putting pieces together as like the characters
are and just you're just it leaves you on the
edge of your seat until the very end and you're
like I don't know what's going on they don't
know what's going on we're out here on this ride
together I'm scared they're scared but yeah I just
yeah it was wild and like has you frustrated with
the characters as they're trying to figure it out
too and yeah it makes me excited I was like dang I
want to see the rest of them yeah because I I from
the little I do know it's like they're kind of
treated as like chapters I think something without
a fact yeah but I don't know like anything that
happens within those chapters I just know that
um yeah obviously the the main killer is is
revealed at the end so obviously he's gonna
probably be in the other ones right um oh my God
but I did I think I called out even though it
was like my brain was getting there when we read
that the cigarettes are not poisonous something
about poisonous and then we heard the blood the
poison in the blood and that's why he dabbed the
cigarette and the blood to maybe give it to Adam
to smoke and then he would maybe die that needs
to be revealed to me yeah well I think that right
they were kind of saying at the end is that the
guy who was jigsaw he was sick so maybe his blood
blood was poisonous yeah because he's like poison
coursing through my veins but I also was like
but why was the letter saying something poisonous
linked with the cigarettes even though it kept
saying they're not why was it that thing was
like a that's the part of a jigsaw that we haven't
unlocked yet I would like to read that note again
and be like what was the link why did he dip
the cigarette in the blood then because I think
he thought it would kill him because he's because
the note said that there was a kill right yes yes
because he is so and then he gave adam the other
one to not kill him yeah right okay but still uh
there I just I don't know I'm mad at the
characters that went in and they didn't
kill him right away no I do love that of course
the smart one in this is the mom who's like let's
get untied we hear him coming fake it fake it girl
thank you she's not great because she has the gun
and can shoot him and like she stays close to him
these are the parts that I'm like uh I hate this I
hate this move away from him grab your daughter or
shoot him in the leg if you don't want to kill a
man shoot him in the leg like come on now what are
we doing here and also hang up with your husband
and call 9-1-1 thank you like why are you like
what do you mean you're locked in a room what does
that mean I'm like girl look at you like you're
locked in her room with your kid what do you mean
is that confusing for you like these things I go
through it you see me you see I'm going through a
downward spiral right now I get so mad at these
characters but it was still very entertaining
super entertaining like so freaking good um I
give it okay we'll give it 10 out of 10 stars
um I'll give it I mean that was fun it was fun I
also want to see more of the little replicas I'm
gonna give it like I'm gonna give it a 7.7 out
of 10 even though those those characters made
me mad this was this was fun this was thrilling
the entire time I really dug the Intrigue and the
Mystery the dumb character moves take it down
a couple points I think for me I'd give it an
eight because that's good I was gonna go eight but
then I was like don't scare dang make me mad Maybe
so mad I just want I just want I want this movie
like if they made it again for characters to be
smarter but the killer to still get away yes
right like he's shot and he's like limping but
he figures out like oh I don't know I don't know
you guys I don't really have the solution but like
uh this was fun we'll have to watch the other
ones there's like a million more oh yeah so
we're in it you guys gotta let us know what you
think do you guys want us to watch the rest of
the saws probably you guys are probably gonna
be like absolutely yes don't forget to leave
a like leave a comment comment tell us what
we missed in this little please yeah because
maybe we're confused by something that you guys
picked up and exactly I'm just trying to get the
answers but don't spoil please because we want
to watch the other ones no spoilers about any
of the other ones guys only comment about what
we have said here today or of the saw number one
okay and also if you're not already patreon you
should become one and and pledge up because then
you could watch all the reactions all of it the
whole the whole thing the whole Gambit with me
the whole thing okay so just get on
it we love you so much and yeah I mean
we'll see you we'll see you soon
see you soon bye foreign [Music]